Let's go next to our caller from the eight
one six area code.
Who's calling today from eight one six?
A David.
This is Jazz from Kansas City, Missouri.
Hey, Jazz, what's going on?
So I was calling to ask you about how you're
voting in November.
OK.
Specifically on a ballot measure.
It looks like Massachusetts will probably
have ranked choice voting on the ballot.
Will you be voting for it?
I've not seen the language of it.
I actually didn't.
I need to get schooled up on what's on the
ballot in November.
So the answer is depending on how it is written.
I very well may and I. I've done a lot of
interviews in segments on a number of different
voting systems.
There's the sort of standard configuration
of ranked choice voting.
There is single transferable vote.
There's a bunch of different configurations.
And I like a lot of them.
Some of them are less than perfectly structured.
And so I need to look at how it's written.
But that is certainly something I would consider
voting for until I actually see the text of
the initiative.
I wouldn't want to say for sure.
Actually, Maine has instant runoff voting,
and I'm pretty sure that's what Massachusetts
is proposing.
And it's the it's it seems like the easiest
to implement system within it given our current
constitutional structure.
But, yeah.
That's another things that are Asian, which
is sometimes the best system, is more complex
constitutionally to implement.
And you also don't want to let the perfect
become the enemy of the good at someone.
Someone once said, I don't know who.
Yeah, yeah, well, first past the post is arguably
the worst.
Right.
But do you think progressives should focus
on electoral reform, like on ballot initiatives
such as the main one and the Massachusetts
one?
Absolutely.
So what for?
For several years now, one of the frame the
framework I've been prioritizing is we need
to fix how politics is financed.
And we need to fix how we vote.
And this can include getting rid of first
past the post.
This can include getting away from the Electoral
College system.
So, yeah, it's like if you care about education
or abortion or climate or whatever, to really
make progress on these issues, you've got
to fix some of the structural problems that
we have.
Health care, I would consider one of those
structural problems in the sense that if you
are stuck at a job merely to avoid losing
health insurance, it's going to be difficult
to be an activist for what you care about.
So absolutely, this should be a priority for
progressives.
OK.
And one last question, if you don't mind.
Sure.
Since Maine has ranked choice voting now and
they're going to be voting in 2020, rank choice
voting.
The instant runoff.
How would you feel about Progressive's in
Maine putting Lisa Savage, the Green Party
candidate, as their number one in the race
against Susan Collins?
I know nothing about her, so I would have
to know.
I mean, I get the question is more of a mathematical
question.
You can vote for the Green Party candidate
without helping Susan Collins.
If you have a system other than first past
the post.
But but even still, given that I know nothing
about her, it wouldn't be appropriate for
me to say, yes, do it, because who knows?
I just don't know enough about her.
Right.
I was more so just asking generally if under
instant runoff system, you think that voting
Green Party as number one would be a good
idea?
Only if you support the Green Party.
What the statement that I can say more generally
is, with such a system, you can vote for the
person you most agree with without fear that
you may be helping the person you're most
opposed to.
That would be how I would generalize the rule.
All right.
Yeah.
Cool.
Sounds good.
All right, my friend.
Thank you very much for the phone call.
Appreciate hearing from you.
Let's go to let's go to our friend Don Tell
from Florida.
Don, tell r how are things going down there?
What would the virus exploding?
Don Taylor, are we muted, we can't hear you.
All right, Don, tell we're going to one more
opportunity I wanted to hear from you, Don
Talbot.
We're not you're not coming through at all.
All right.
No, Don, tell that's too bad, was wanted to
hear from him.